and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review hella boy to the Golden
Army
the greatest movie I've ever seen in my
life
there's this guy called Hellboy except
he's not really a boy he's a big Angry
Men with pepperoni coming out of his
head and he teams up with this fish man
who kind of looks like the creature from
the Blue Lagoon if he was gay and
there's this woman who can control fire
and most of the time she's covered in
fire I know you expect me to make a
sexual joke about how attractive she is
who she's so hot she's so hot she's on
fire she's so hot she's steaming but I'd
like to think I would pass that childish
humor back to the review and there's
this Prince guy who kinda looks like the
singer print in that he's got beady eyes
a high-pitched voice and he's white and
he sends out all these evil little
creatures then you're called the tooth
fairy and I was like two fairies she's
so pretty is not that kind of tooth
fairy you're gonna give me money are you
I wish the Tooth Fairy would visit me I
pulled out three of my teeth one time
get them under my pillow
and the next morning I got jumped she
gave me three identical teeth and look
just like mine what a whore
so the Prince guy is like I'm going to
at least the Golden Army and destroy all
of mankind haha and Hellboy is like
doodoo bother me attorney drink and
there's a German robot who operates a
magic smoke I told you smoke was magical
and I see all sorts of things when I
smoke like German robots and fix people
and hell boys and women who are on fire
I'm sorry I may not have seen this movie
some of these movies it's so hard to
tell like terms of endearment that was
about a psychotic rutabaga right I get
so confused
oh well the other thing that happened in
this movie slash possible craig fantasy
was this giant black creature popped up
and then a giant broad person popped up
and then these giant golden guys popped
up everybody was so big it's my booty in
the world
so that Hellboy and the Fishman get
drunk together and sing songs
yeah I'm pretty convinced this was a
crack fantasy when the Prince comes in
he's like give me the golden crown and
Hellboy is like til drinking so Hellboy
teams up with the fire woman the German
robot and the fish man I definitely need
to see somebody and they take on the
golden army which look like giant alarm
clocks that want to kill you so elbow is
like telling you to do it princess like
and so helpfully wins the fight and then
he's like to me and Hellboy is like yeah
Prince is like then I'll kill you and
helper is like very fair but then the
Prince dies because the princess kills
herself you see the prince in the
princess her brother and sister and so
they can feel each other's pain so when
she said to herself he also feels the
effect and blood is oozing out of them
and then they turned to these weird
plastic statues I am check into a rehab
clinic tomorrow